SENATE TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE
WILL COME TO ORDER. GOOD
AFTERNOON AND WELCOME. WE HAVE
FIVE MEASURES ON TODAY'S AGENDA,
AND THEY'RE ALL ON CONSENT. THE
PROPOSED CONSENT ITEMS SHOULD BE
LISTED AT YOUR DESK, BUT LET ME
ANNOUNCE THEM. ITEM ONE ACR 203
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER HART. ITEM
TWO ACR 215 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WALDRON. ITEM THREE AG. AJR 19
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER JUAN
CARRILLO. ITEM FOUR SCR 13 BY
SENATOR ROTH. ITEM FIVE SCR 169
BY SENATOR DODD. LET'S ESTABLISH
A QUORUM, AND WE ASK THE
ASSISTANT TO PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. SENATORS. CORTEZ. HERE.
CORTEZ. HERE. NILO. HERE. NILO.
HERE. ALAN ALAN. HERE.
ARCHULETA. BECKER HERE. BECKER.
HERE. SHAKESPEARE. SHAKESPEARE.
HERE. DALLY. DALLY. HERE. DODD.
DODD. HERE. GONZALEZ. LIMÓN.
NEWMAN. NEWMAN. HERE. NGUYEN.
PORTANTINO FOR THE RECORD. ALAN.
IS THERE. I'M HERE. PORTANTINO
HERE. SEYARTO. I'M HERE. CARTER.
HERE. UMBERG. THERE HELPFUL. ALL
RIGHT. QUORUM HAS BEEN
ESTABLISHED, DO WE HAVE A MOTION
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR? SO
MOVED. MOVE, WE DO HAVE A MOTION
BY SENATOR NEWMAN, AND I'LL ASK
COMMITTEE ASSISTANT TO PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. SENATORS
CORTESE A CORTESE I NILO NILO I
ALLEN. ALAN I ARCHULETA. BECKER.
BECKER I SHAKESPEARE,
SHAKESPEARE I DILLY DALLY I DODD
I DODD I GONZALEZ. LIMÓN NEWMAN.
NEWMAN I NGUYEN PORTANTINO
PORTANTINO I CIERTO CIERTO I
UMBERG.
TEN ZERO. WE WILL LEAVE THE
CONSENT ITEMS ON CALL, BUT WE'RE
ONLY GOING TO DO THAT FOR TEN
MINUTES. AND WE'LL SOON BE
TURNING THE GAVEL OVER AT THE
APPOINTED HOUR TO SENATOR
SHAKESPEARE FOR SUBCOMMITTEE
MEETING. SO TEN MORE MINUTES.
WE'LL KEEP, WE'LL KEEP THE ROLL
OPEN. WE'LL BASICALLY RECESS IN
THE MEANWHILE. FOR PURPOSES OF
AUDIO, VIDEO. AND THE SERGEANTS
AWARENESS. THANK YOU.
BE BACK. ALL RIGHT. WE'LL ASK
THE ASSISTANT TO OPEN THE ROLL
AND CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS THE
CONSENT CALENDAR WITH THE CHAIR
AND VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
SENATORS ARCHULETA. ARCHULETA,
AYE. GONZALEZ LIMÓN NGUYEN
UMBERG. ALL RIGHT, WE'RE AT 11
ZERO ON CALL. THANK YOU. WE WILL
INFORMALLY RECESS THIS TIME
UNTIL WE GET ADDITIONAL MEMBERS
HERE. KEEP THAT ITEM ON CALL.
AS THE ASSISTANT TO OPEN THE
ROLL. THIS IS THE CONSENT
CALENDAR WITH THE CHAIR AND VICE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. SENATORS.
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ. AYE LIMÓN
NGUYEN. UMBERG ALL RIGHT. WE'RE
AT 12 ZERO. WE'LL LEAVE, CONSENT
CALENDAR ON CALL FOR A FEW
MINUTES LONGER. I KNOW SENATOR
RAMON IS ON HER WAY. RIGHT ON
CUE. GO AHEAD AND OPEN UP THE
ROLL, PLEASE. THIS IS THE
CONSENT CALENDAR, SENATORS.
LIMÓN AYE, AYE. NGUYEN UMBERG.
ALL RIGHT, WE'RE 13 ZERO. WE'LL
KEEP THE ROLL OPEN FOR A FEW
MORE MINUTES. THIS I'LL BE BACK
FOR LAWCENTER. OKAY. I'M GOING
TO CALL.
ALL RIGHT. WE'VE BEEN INFORMED
THAT ALL MEMBERS WHO ARE GOING
TO VOTE HAVE VOTED, SO WE'LL
CLOSE THE ROLL AT THIS TIME. AND
THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS OUT
OFFICIALLY WITH A 13 TO 0 VOTE.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NOW WE'RE GOING TO RECESS, WE
ARE GOING TO ADJOURN THE SENATE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE MEETING.
AND SEPARATELY, THE SENATE
SUBCOMMITTEE ON LAUSANNE WILL BE
CONVENING, AND MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE,
INCLUDING MYSELF, WILL BE
PARTICIPATING IN THAT MEETING.
BUT THAT IS NOT NOTICED TO START
UNTIL 2 P.M. SO WE WILL ADJOURN.
WE WILL BE IN THE ROOM UNTIL 2
P.M. OR A LITTLE BEFORE THAT.
WHEN SENATOR BURR COMES BACK TO
MAKE ANNOUNCEMENTS AND START
THAT MEETING. THANK YOU.